we looked down on the ground and saw a
sort of a series of what look like rocks
in a in a formation sometimes you get
clay pipes and the like out there but
this looks a bit different
conservationist joe davis had stumbled
across a giant ichthyosaur skeleton a
so-called sea dragon that existed at the
same time dinosaurs lived on earth a lot
of people spend their careers looking
for something like this my kids have now
named me jurassic
so
that's quite that's quite amusing a team
of experts were brought in to lead the
excavation in rutland what they
unearthed is one of the most exciting
finds ever for british paleontologists
not only is this the the largest
ichthyosaur skeleton ever found in
britain but it's also the the largest
complete skeleton of any prehistoric
reptile found here in the in the uk as
well which is an amazing amazing find
the 180 million year old bones were
carefully removed well this is the
complete ichthyosaur skeleton 10 meters
long in a series of field jackets made
out of plaster of paris so that we could
lift it safely now safely in storage in
shropshire the skeleton will be studied
to find secrets of the past
will tell us about that snapshot of life
at 181 million years ago and we can only
predict future climate changes by
understanding how climates have changed
in the past
this small scale model shows what it
would have looked like the real size of
this creature is staggering to get an
idea of just how large this ichthyosaur
was take a look at this this is the
skull of a killer whale completely
dwarfed by the enormous skull of the sea
dragon
it was unearthed during a year of
unprecedented discoveries last month
scientists announced they'd found this
perfectly preserved dinosaur embryo in
china it's always been exciting to be a
paleontologist it's fantastic to find
things like this but now in the 21st
century we have all sorts of tools at
our disposal that previous generations
of paleontologists never had they really
helped us interpret the finds in a lot
more detail than people used to be able
to do
detail from millions of years ago that
can help us understand the world today
becky johnson sky news shropshire